obviously people remember the Aleppo
moment sure how do you feel about it
well that was it was going to happen I
would apophis eyes that it happened to
Trump about a hundred and fifty times
yeah all right well okay it happens to
me well what do you do when something
like that happens well they each had a
billion eight so when it came to golf
they had the firepower to come back now
to great by the way can I just ask you
been gas right not cops
thank you hi this is Nick Gillespie with
reason and today we are talking with
two-term governor of New Mexico and
two-time Libertarian Party presidential
candidate Gary Johnson governor Johnson
thanks for talking Nick appreciate you
doing this so you are in DC and we're
talking before you go talk at CPAC the
annual convention of conservative action
people in DC why are you speaking at
CPAC well I think it's an opportunity to
give a libertarian perspective on things
now I'm gonna be on a panel when it
comes to economics and Tax Policy so
that is a that is a Trump plus the
reduction of taxes okay well I was gonna
say I was going to ask what did what do
you think about Trump so far I mean you
ran against Trump and you did
historically well for a Libertarian
Party candidate you know against Donald
Trump and Hillary Clinton what do you
you know Trump's been in office over a
year what is your evaluation well he has
not told the truth building a wall
across the border is crazy now he did
say he was gonna build a wall across the
border but said he wasn't going to
involve himself in states rights right
or he was gonna stand up for states
rights and here we have Jeff Sessions
that has come out very vocally against
marijuana ultimately they that may lead
to legislation that will not make
marijuana a class one narcotic which is
result those are two things though where
Trump's bluster or his bark is worse
he's got a lot of bark but no
because we haven't actually started
building the border wall and sessions is
saying I'm gonna you know let's let's
start looking at these states that have
legalized marijuana but nothing has
happened
nothing is happening and it like I say
it may lead the legislation on the
dreamers you know hey here it is we may
have legislation that clears all this up
but his rhetoric looking for a position
in his cabinet which seems to be acting
out but now I mean so these are so
you're set I mean in a weird way Trump
is actually delivering the opposite of
what he promised there's no wall we may
get to drink dreamers may be legalized
and pot maybe D scheduled or rescheduled
but that isn't something that he's
advocating but as a as a consequence of
what he's doing that may actually happen
you mentioned you know on economics or
on Tax Policy he obviously he and the
Republicans put through a major tax plan
do you like that tax plan and had it how
does it stack up to what you were
arguing for on the on the campaign you
know that that corporate tax rates lower
to twenty percent that's a positive I
was advocating zero corporate tax which
I think would be amazing and that
individuals that we would do away with
income tax that we would abolish the IRS
I just think that that would have an
enormous positive impact on all of our
lives including being being able to fund
government and that would have been
replaced by essentially a national sales
tax well in in what I advocated was was
that we switched then to a consumption
tax and I held up the Fair Tax as a
model for how you would would or could
accomplish that and certainly Trump's or
the Republican tax reform whatever else
you can say about it it really does
build in bigger and bigger deficits and
it doesn't simplify things yeah and
that's the that's the half what about
spending I mean that's the if you want
to hold an optimism for Trump and the
future is that he would actually at some
point address spending but he hasn't
spending has
you know increased so what difference
does it make whether it's a Democrat or
a Republican oh and that's the that's
where I come in
what about regulation do you think Trump
has been good I mean particularly as a
western state governor he's he's kind of
pulled back the EPA a little bit is that
I mean talk in in relation to both what
Trump has done but also your experience
as of western state governor with what
New Mexico is like basically more
federal lands than as a percentage of
its mass than almost any other state
right well western states you have that
from yeah and west of the so so here it
is Washington DC east of the Mississippi
there is absolutely no comprehension
whatsoever of what public lands actually
are
well west of the Mississippi Mississippi
you got all these public lands and they
passed laws regarding public lands like
access to public lands which you and I
we look at that and we think well yeah
you should have access to public lands
well it's not even possible to have
access to because they're laid out in
checkerboard fashion so leaving those
decisions to the states the the
deregulation if you will getting the
federal government off the backs of
states that are well-meaning yeah you
bet that's a good thing that's a good
thing and what about at the FDA Trump
you know I mean his his appointee seems
to have pulled back from some of the
over-regulation of medical devices and
pharmaceuticals all positive companies
are not going to be able to sell
products that are dangerous to the
public because there are attorneys out
there and I think attorneys do a much
better job of policing than the federal
government but then you you also
mentioned but here
Trump has this press conference where I
am going to challenge the pharmaceutical
industry to come up with a non-addictive
substitute for opioids mmm hello
what about cannabis marijuana come on so
there's a there's a there's a deafness
that exists but
and all of this deregulation that is in
fact happening and I only guess at this
because I don't know the specifics but I
wish that he would articulate what he's
doing and why that I think is a very
important part of governing yeah talk
about you mentioned his rhetoric as
being you know awful and divisive how
does his failure to kind of articulate
either larger principles when it comes
to deregulation or you know on that
level he seems to be mostly silent he
deregulates up but doesn't explain why
it's good but then when it comes to
things like immigration he's over the
top in you know people coming from
[ __ ] countries blah blah blah what
how how does his rhetoric influence your
views of him well that they influenced
my views on him in a neck in a very
negative way gosh the getting elected
president United States come on we all
recognize that he has an agenda and saw
that up front well how about telling us
why there are benefits to this now when
it comes to immigration when it comes to
marriage equality woman's right to
choose I you know what I I just I don't
buy into his arguments at all but at
least he perhaps tries an argue arguing
those points the deregulation part the
getting into the weeds of policy wise
you know that was I kind of found that
interesting as governor of New Mexico
and yes I think I did an incredible I
think I turned the whole system on its
head but I was upfront about everything
it was that I was doing so my legacy is
well gee I didn't necessarily agree with
anything Gary Johnson did but you know
what he he had reasons for it and we
understood what those reasons were do
you think Trump overall would is better
than Hillary Clinton would have been as
president I think we would have kind of
a myriad of other issues with Hillary
that would probably be equally as
equally as bad and
that was something that I said during
the election so one or the other and it
would have been would have been horrible
eat I think it would be horrible if
Hillary would have been president but I
think Trump's got is horrible also as
somebody who was involved in the 2016
presidential campaign do you have any
take on whether or not Russian agents of
influence were screwing around with you
or with the you know with vote totals
that seems to be a lingering shadow well
okay it's it's okay for the it's not
okay for the Russians to do it but it's
okay for Hillary Clinton to do it there
was an article that appeared well but I
agree with that
let me speak let me speak to you about
what happened to me not that you're not
aware about six weeks to go in the
campaign the New York Times comes out
with an article that says watch out
Hillary Johnson is garnering more
millennial support than you are that was
on a Friday on a Saturday 200 oh I'll
say 200 internet trolls descended on
MySpace and now you had 20 news
organizations call it fake news if you
want but you had 20 pop-ups that
appeared here's what Gary Johnson has
said and if you read any of them you
probably read a few your takeaway was
that this is the dumbest guy that's ever
walked the planet and at that point I
stopped googling myself and to this day
I don't google myself I don't look at
whether people are saying about me do
you assume that was Russian BOTS or was
that there were articles or there were
articles written that Hillary Clinton
spent 50 million dollars to discredit me
now was it 50 million well we spent 12
million on our campaign that's what we
raised so did it affect the election did
it affect me well like I say Google me
today and your takeaway is gonna be as
good we didn't have that guy so it's I
mean what you're saying is that or if I
may are you saying that the question
of Russian influence is less important
than the ways in which people were
everybody was trying everything
everybody was trying to manipulate this
and when it comes to the Internet I mean
you pay for you pay for those where does
where does your website pop up well if
you're talking about 50 million dollars
gee the first 20 things you're gonna
read are gonna be potentially subsidized
by that 20 million dollars when it comes
to the Russian influence I just read
where they among other things just
promoted Bernie Sanders well that would
have been an that was a negative that
was a negative for Hillary Clinton but
she also was bringing her own kind of
baggage to the party right but well let
me ask you if you know if it was a
question of Hillary Clinton being able
to say okay flying monkeys go destroy
Gary Johnson here's fifty million
dollars here's twenty million dollars
would that mean that you would want to
limit the ways in which people can spend
their campaign money no but it's it is
so back to policy back to getting
elected being in office what what
potentially could be done to fix that
Nick I can't tell you what potentially
could be done to fix that but there are
ideas out there and certainly the best
ideas launched would be in this case
Facebook themselves Twitter themselves
dealing with this but looking at
government and even as a libertarian
look a take away from reading Hayek is
is if you're an elected official if
you're in the public policy arena you
should always be looking to improve
things always improve things so that
having been governor of New Mexico that
was always my tact what to stay on the
2016 campaign a bit obviously people
remember the Aleppo moment Sheriff you
you know how do you feel about that now
it's you know it's been a while and it's
in the rearview mirror you know were
there moments was that a turning point
do you think in your campaign
had he yes or no how do you feel about
it well that was it was going to happen
it you know I I would hypothesize that
it happened to Trump about a hundred and
fifty times yeah all right well okay it
happens to me well what do you do when
something like that happens well we had
they each had a billion eight so when it
came to Goff's they had the firepower to
come back now to great by the way could
I just ask you mean gas right back
coughs well thank you okay this is a gas
right this is a real time okay so but
yeah I mean it's also golf I said God
you'll see now that there there we go
you know that that could be a that could
be a testament to my intellect right
there yeah
but it's basically they were able to
bounce back and it is what did so so for
us immediately within days of that I did
a major pala a major foreign policy
speech in Chicago and guess what nobody
carried it well you know our firepower
was very limited yeah but we did all the
right things and it was gonna happen
gaffes happen you we are I always
thought that honesty would rule the day
I always thought that integrity would
rule the day I always thought that
telling the truth rule the day do you
need us do you hate America now
I don't hate America I hate hate America
I hate I hate politics I think political
office today is toxic so are you you
know here you are it's too you know
whatever it is February late February
early March of 2018 you're speaking at
CPAC are you thinking about running
again in the future absolutely not no
I'm done I'm done with elected political
office but my political arm our America
we're gonna dedicate ourselves to will
how do you change this and don't you
have to vote for don't you have to vote
for another party to change this and so
libertarians I think really have an
opportunity here and the opportunity
rests solely in having really good
candidate
and having some really good candidates
win and the our America initiative is
your nonprofit that looks at a variety
of policy issues and is it affiliated
with the Libertarian Party or you still
are you I mean you were a two-term
governor as a Republican you've
renounced your Republican estill fully
enmeshed in the Libertarian Party or had
it how do you think well by a meshed I
do think that the Libertarian Party
emulates the feelings of most Americans
and I summarized that during the 2016
election by saying most Americans I
think are fiscally conservative and
socially they don't care you know
socially liberal
you should be able to make decisions in
your own life as long as those decisions
don't adversely affect others I think
most people feel that way a Republican
party doesn't emulate that and the
Democrat Party certainly doesn't emulate
that either when it comes to dollars and
cents when neither of them do when it
comes to dollars and cents right right
and foreign policy too they seem to be
pretty similar right it's all lockstep
and you know the first constitution the
founding fathers they never visualize or
never believe that there would be
political parties and if there were
gonna be political parties that might be
the demise of our republic in terms of
foreign policy in the in the
presidential kind of math mess of issues
or massive issues obviously terrorism
like bothers people in a way but did you
find that people you know it were they
responsive to your vision of a non
interventionist foreign policy or of
having a defense to partner as opposed
to no or no they weren't I think
everybody and that's the that's the fear
that politics really are people running
for office that look drugs are the
scourge of the earth terrorism is the
scourge of the earth Afghanistan is the
scourge in here Iran is the scourge of
the earth elect me and I will protect
you from all of these threats and evils
and that's what politics is and
never been a part of that well one of
the things you used to say a lot during
the campaign was Google Gary Johnson
you're no longer doing that you said but
you also used to say uber everything
let's get uber for everything do you
still believe in that and yes
will that carry that will that carry
American America forward in progress I I
absolutely believe that that that
whatever it is that you do in your life
if you can directly deal with the end
user and get paid such that's a good
thing and I look at uber as a model for
that you've got drivers that are owned
their own cars and I realize that's in
not all the cases and maybe it is but
you know you own your own cars you're
your own boss you can do what you want
you give a piece to uber because they've
arranged to to to do all this well that
could be a model for plumbers that could
be a model for lawyers that could be a
model for electric you you name it
that's I do ultimately think that that's
the way things are going to evolve
eliminate the middleman
let me get paid the $75 an hour instead
of getting paid $25 an hour and now we
raise all sorts of liability issues but
insurance can change that a person
becomes insured from a liability
standpoint to be able to do anything if
you did away with income tax holy cow
you could go help your neighbor and get
paid to help your neighbor you know your
neighbor needs help moving some boxes
hey I'll pay you 20 bucks to do that
well today if you take that 20 bucks
you're technically you're in violation
of law because you're not going to claim
that as income one of the issues that is
port was particularly front and center
to you was drug legalization
particularly pot legal or the end of pot
prohibition marijuana prohibition you're
involved with some marijuana companies
what's going on in that area of your
life of your business well currently I'm
involved with CB 1 which you know they
do have a website but it's a hedge fund
by the buying stock of publicly traded
companies in the marijuana space very
exciting and I do believe that it could
be one of the biggest investment
opportunities in the next decade because
65% of Americans now support legalizing
marijuana maybe it's not 65 but it's the
highest that it's ever been before
it's it's going to happen and it's it's
a positive I mean and I say a positive
because the alternatives from a medical
standpoint opioids opioids replacement
for opioids and on the alcohol front I
haven't had a drink of alcohol in 30
years I do use marijuana occasionally
and but it's much much safe you would
drink and you would get drunk right I
would drink and why have one beer when
you could have three and RIT and catch a
buzz yeah and then three beers the next
morning really had an effect for me it
oh a for me for some I have no problem
with anybody drinking as long as they're
not doing harm to others but then so
with pot what you know what does pot do
for you that's better than drinking and
and I you know I understand there's the
large arguments which I mostly agree
with to the extent that I'm aware of
them that pot is less dangerous and it
screws up your mind less it doesn't hurt
your liver
you know you don't have to smoke it
anymore but do you get high when you
take when you use pots
well I do and I always said that it kind
of it's it's a mind roll brain roll well
rearrange the bookshelves in a good way
not a bad way so that's my experience
yeah and for anybody that has problems
with substances and really there's a
very small amount of people that do have
problems with marijuana that's did you
that's gonna always exist what was you
know it and you see pot or marijuana
derived products as one one possible way
of lessening the reliance on opioids
whether we're talking about heroin
or we're talking about prescription drug
psychosis what it would you were
governor of New Mexico what were the
drugs that you were most often dealing
with that that were causing real social
harms not simply because of their you
know their status as black mark well
there's there's the there's the
perception and there's the reality and
the perception was was that when I was
governor of New Mexico that drugs were
the scourge of the earth well Maria and
including marijuana well the reality and
I'm governor of New Mexico reality half
of what we spend on law enforcement half
of what we spend in the course and half
of what we spend in the prisons is
drug-related do you know that in 2017
the number one arrest offense in the
United States was still is still
marijuana and I'll bet that's the case
in 2018 so with all this talk about
legalization that is still the fact and
it's wrong it's wrong to criminalize an
activity that like I say you're not
doing any harm to anyone arguably other
than yourself
should that be an arrest able offense I
don't believe so well
what how can you sketch out the the
scenarios you see it where pot is now
kind of I mean it is legal at the state
level in a handful of states and
Massachusetts is actually going to join
the pot club the marijuana club later
this year with recreational legalization
it's you know in dozens of states it is
medical marijuana is legal what what
happens next because there is going to
be a showdown isn't there between the
federal government or federal laws and
state one thing that the federal
government needs to do is to D scheduled
marijuana as a class one narcotic
alongside of heroin give me a break
so there is all this conjecture there's
all this hypothesis of what what are the
benefits of marijuana
well Nick there's no research happening
in the United States is happening in
other countries but the research needs
to take place and will take place
if marijuana is D scheduled as a class
one or kind of narcotic so very simple
step for the federal government
declassify marijuana president United
States could order the could order the
Surgeon General to do that the were a
week or so after a particularly
disturbing mass shooting I guess to say
one is less to be a more disturbing than
the other where is wrong
17 17 people were killed at a school in
Florida did you have to deal with that
kind of sure and how do you deal with
that as a governor or as a chief
executive and is there is there a good
solution to this type of violence what I
said numerous times during the
presidential campaign and as governor
look week we need to be open to a
discussion on how you keep guns out of
the hands of mentally ill individuals to
say anything other than that would be
stupid so an open mind on how do we deal
with this but Nick I have not heard any
suggestions that would actually bring
about real real change
president Trump saying that we should
arm teachers as governor of New Mexico
after Columbine I was asked what do you
do to prevent a further Columbine and my
answer was look you're not gonna want to
hear the answer but you would lessen the
impact of any any shooter active shooter
by requiring the teachers be armed and I
am not advocating that but yesterday now
or this morning I read that 75% of
teachers don't want to be armed that
means that 25% would actually armed
themselves if allowed to do that
wouldn't that and again I'm not saying
this is the solution but here's a here
is a concrete way of deterring these
things from happening
these active shooting from happening in
the future if 25% of teachers are
carrying to me that would be a deterrent
to a lot of I think it would be a
deterrent maybe it doesn't turn out that
way but I have to feel
forget about forget about the actual
crossfire that would occur forget about
an actual gun fight that's gonna occur
think about the fact that well gee I'm
not gonna do the school thing anymore
because I'm not good people that
contemplate this kind of thing aren't
gonna think of schools anymore because
I'm gonna end up dead and and many of
them don't care anyway and that's so
that's why it's not a it's not a
solution to it but it certainly would
have to be a deterrent do you you know
in a broader sense do you feel like even
since the 2006 campaign has the ability
of America to kind of have these
conversations is it is it growing or is
it shrinking is it staying the same as
it always a struggle I mean because in
no ways maybe it maybe it is growing
maybe it is growing because the looking
at the outrage over sessions and what
he's saying regarding marijuana well
because of what he's doing when it comes
to marijuana which is wanting to crack
down on marijuana in fact it may it may
turn out to be the opposite may turn out
right well well you know let's let's end
on this now one of the things that I
found genuinely interesting apart from
you know generally agreeing with your
policy positions it was your demeanor as
a as a politician to say like honesty
let's talk about this stuff you you're
also a baby boomer right what year were
you born 53 okay so you're a bit you're
about 10 years younger I guess or six or
seven years younger than than Trump or
Hillary all of that kind of you know
Bernie Sanders these were early baby
boomers and they were all incredibly
negative and cynical about America I
mean Trump talked about American carnage
in his inauguration speech Hillary
Clinton was talking about how everything
was kind of going to hell in a
handbasket Bernie Sanders is you know
like I mean he lived in a world that was
you know like out of a
rascals short or how you know like
Hoovervilles and black and white right
you were optimistic what you know what
undergird what undergirded your optimism
and what you know what keeps it going in
the face of situations where you know
people are saying oh my god they're
killing kids you know the economy's in
the crapper
you know China's taking over one of it
one of the offshoots of Trump and and
that all really hasn't happened but the
talk of cutting back and and
entitlements need to be reformed which
Trump isn't touching but because of his
rhetoric I think now for example we're
seeing companies step up and and
actually doing more there's more of a
seem seems to me today that there's more
of a corporate responsibility that's
rising to the top well that's that's the
private sector that's rising to the top
so I remain optimistic and if government
weren't there to provide all the
services that it provides we as
Americans would be filling in that gap
we would be filling it in completely I'm
completely in that belief and we would
be buzzed on top of it we would be happy
by buzz yes we would be buzz okay so it
could be a natural high or it could be a
an artificial high but we'd be in a
better place I went government yields
and ruber everything so I'm making a
whole lot more money I'm able to do
things that I haven't been able to do
before because I'm making more money one
of the things that Trump said is that by
repatriating which I believe when if we
would repatriate all that corporate
money that's overseas that we would see
that money invested in the United States
well it's it's happened so that's the
that's another positive on on the Trump
side well we will leave it there we've
been talking with Governor Gary Johnson
a two-term governor of New Mexico a
two-time Libertarian Party presidential
candidate governor thanks so much for
talking thanks for a reason I'm Nicholas
Peck
you
[Music]